two of the best metaphysical synthesis
are sri aurobindo and the mother mira
alfasa
their success with uncovering truth lies
in their east-west
upbringings able to bring together
spirituality
with science and have dialectic on the
nature of reality
this is a distillation of their wisdoms
grouped by most salient categories
1. oroboros the end
whichever begins again an eternal spiral
that does not end in an ultimate point
it is the adventure of consciousness and
joy
the child-like laughter of the infinite
2 joining heaven and earth
aurobindo's first secret is persistent
refusal to cut life in two
never separate your inner and outer
world
the whole secret is to join the two
experiences of
heaven and earth into one
a new earth wherein the truth shall
dwell
as if we took on artist consciousness
to see the full revelation of glory
in the design of the universe
3. man is a transitional being
man is a finite seeming infinity
mind is a passage not a culmination
evolution of human life into a life
divine the unconquerable
impulse of man towards god
light bliss freedom and immortality
is next on the nature chain to evolve
beyond mind the ascent
to the divine life is the human journey
the work of works the acceptable
sacrifice this alone is
man's real business the justification
of his existence
mind is a clumsy interlude between
subconscious and super conscious of the
godhead
childlike laughter and ecstasy of the
infinite
are calling universal being
is concealed by fragmentation in an
ocean of unconscious
4. reintegrate the god in man
the base of all spiritual knowledge is
consciousness
of identity through knowledge of the
self
knowledge of the universe in each
man there is a god and to make him
manifest is the aim of divine life
the stifling of the individual is the
stifling of the god
in man to abolish ignorance
go inwards unite consciousness with
god and with all existence
reintegrate the god in man
manifest god in the body
i am he thou
art that all this is the brahman
this self is the brahman
be missioned to lead man in the
ignorance
towards the light of the divine
consciousness
i do not want millions of followers it
will be enough
if i can get 100 men completely
empty of petty egoism in acting
as instruments of god
self-ignorance is therefore the root
of all the perversity of our existence
egocentrism is our defense and
rock of safety against the cosmic
and the infinite the atheist is god
playing hide and seek with himself the
theist
saw the shadow of god and clutched at it
the kingdom of god is within you
culminating in knowledge by identity
go to the true source
within the well of honey
covered by the rock
five yoga the art of
conscious self-finding a union of your
individuality with the universal and
transcendent
existence each human must find their own
union their own unique self-realization
from the buffet of infinite
combinatorics
have two painters ever seen the same
landscape in the same way
emphasize spiritual gnosis of the divine
spark within over faith in teachings and
traditions
your work on earth is to establish
a direct contact between the supreme
and the individual blind determinisms
that presently rule the world like
death suffering and war will give way to
a new
luminous spiritual revolution
when we recognize that nothing is other
anymore your only task is to discover
the truth of your being
ascending consciousness is opening the
aperture
our legacy of millions of years of
animal nature
drives our tensions today
yoga unlearns habits from animal
evolution
yoga is not here to teach as much as it
is to
catalyze unlearning your consciousness
resisting
evolution is where the battle of the
world is being
fought there exists a single
knot of life where the destiny of the
world
takes shape ego is the most formidable
of the knots
which keeps us tied to the ignorance
yoga is accelerated evolution becoming
the battlefield against the knot of
darkness
ignorance laboring towards knowledge
a single human overcoming the
difficulties of transformation
butterfly effects around the world
descent is the main characteristic of
arubindo's yoga
bringing down vibrations of the future
to accelerate the cleansing process
the divine fulfillment of life is the
descent
of the new consciousness attained by the
ascent
the transformation of consciousness must
happen
right in the heart of davos hollywood
silicon valley global 500 ceos
worldwide presidents and congresses
the seeker verifies in vivo the
principle of the world's oneness
seeing all beings and things in one
interconnected vision the realization
must be
constant in the waking state for it to
be truly possessed
no longer an ego but only consciousness
existence peace bliss
eternity infinity
this limitation to our surface existence
this unconsciousness of our highest
as our inmost self is our first
our capital ignorance the spiritual life
finds its most
potent expression in the man who lives
the ordinary life of men
in the strength of the yoga
you must reach truth and enable creation
to follow
you don't do yoga for yourself alone
you do it for everybody unintentionally
automatically six
step number one silence the mind
silence is our passage into eternity
everything depends on our determination
with silence
peace immobility are the basics for
transformation silence is one of the
most
powerful and convincing experiences of
which the human mind is capable
super consciousness becomes manifest to
us when the chaos of the mind is stilled
silence enables discernment truth begins
in cellular equanimity
carry within you an inviolable retreat
of
peace go within to this great
silence and everything changes there is
a certainty
peace like a shipwrecked man who has
found
a rock no matter the turmoil outside
we cross a threshold within cellular
immobility
only a delightful smile then we begin to
know peace
he becomes the master of his own
responses to the world's contacts
no longer the slave of external touches
do not let mind set up house for itself
let everything settle and clarify in
silence
silence is clean in itself
take your interior successes and ground
them
in the exterior world when
mind is silent words speech
action everything comes automatically
with striking exactness and speed a much
lighter way of living exact knowledge
needed
falls like a drop of light in the
silence of the consciousness
only move when you are moved by the
divine
we become so sensitive we can read the
tiniest things the most insignificant
events of
daily life affecting people's
evolutionary process
the guidance begins from within exposing
every movement to the light of truth
repelling what is false obscure opposed
to the divine realization
disentangling confusions purifying all
harmonizing the whole nature putting
everything in spiritual order
we embrace all existence become
god feel and hear and touch the eternal
make a deeper and closer unity of self
and the world in a transcendent
realization
an invasion by the infinite
this new consciousness has itself the
nature of infinity
eternity and immortality embracing all
of existence
uniting the manifested with what is
above it
the life falls quiet of a spiritualized
consciousness
the body ceases to need and to clamor
the soul itself merges into the
spiritual silence
engaging with this silent state during
all daily activities
is self-realization the task of the
seeker
is to keep the true vibration alive
art tries to call down the great
inexpressible vibration
when consciousness is released from the
thousands of mental clouds
it becomes joy the seeker's wall
between the inner and outer loses
consistency
a change in texture of being lighter
more transparent porous
unification of the entire being by
breaking down the wall
between the inner and outer nature
individual
into cosmic consciousness
the ultimate is everywhere in each being
body atom in the world
see a large interconnected comprehensive
universal play intuitive knowledge sees
things as sides of an indivisible whole
all is fused within a single experience
global undivided eternal vision
fight the most strenuous battles in the
unconscious without
ever feeling tired 8 billion
difficulties to overcome
entangled in the not of life
silence entry into infinite emptiness
is the condition of a greater knowledge
power
and bliss becoming filled with the wine
of god
plunged into the incommunicable super
conscious
of the absolute whence
shall he have grief how shall one be
deluded
who sees everywhere the oneness
seven adverse forces symmetry
first signs of psychic opening love
and joy as calm and deep as the sea
liberated consciousness lives in
infinity
always with this contagious
infinite joy we help others dispel their
shadows
our downs are in exact proportion
symmetry to our capacity of ascent
you only ascend in proportion to the new
resistance
you are ready to meet the adverse
forces are sudden violent swooping down
upon the seeker with rage in seconds he
becomes
another man totally forgetting his
purpose
goals meaning joy peace
all obstacles whatever their nature
always turn out later
to be helpful assists of a truth whose
meaning and purpose we do not yet know
time you have an experience indicating
progress
in your transformation you are delivered
difficulties
revolts illnesses everything starting to
great
you begin to understand how things work
vedic rishis called subconscious shadow
forces
sun thieves evil is not
outside it is within and below
he has to conquer in himself the forces
of egoistic
falsehood and disorder then conquer the
same adverse and inexhaustible forces
in the world much of the time we will
not get
access to work with the shadows of our
closest family and friends
but we'll get to with complete strangers
what size share of human disease do you
have the courage to face
and take upon yourself we find
our self-finding in their self-finding
and self-realization mirrors
mind attains its self-fulfillment when
it becomes
a pure mirror of the truth of being
civilization is a mirror of our
consciousness
perfect correlation between inner states
and outer circumstances
as inside so outside
conscious collaborators in our own
evolution
accepting the challenge or letting it
pass by us
unperverted by ignorant stimulus of
desire
food can be reduced to a hygienic
minimum without bloating
and disease our humanity
is the conscious meeting place between
the finite
and infinite this spiritual light
power knowledge delight from above
descends beyond the mind and heart which
are
always the easiest to reach and
illuminate to occupy the whole nature of
being from top to bottom
pervading more fully the life and body
shaking the foundations of the
unconscious
the individual existence becomes dimly
aware of the self and seeks
first nervously and then ardently to
master
use and enjoy the play an
ordering self-knowledge law of guiding
truth
harmonious self-vision without this
the world would be nothing but a
confused uncertainty
the tree and all its branches are
contained
in the seed this reality is
consciousness returning again
to itself the play of self-concealing
and self-finding is one of the most
strenuous
joys that conscious being can give to
itself
a play of extreme attractiveness
ignorance stumbles towards the knowledge
shedding its limitations blossoming into
truth consciousness
every drop of honey can taste itself all
the others
in the whole honeycomb
eight consciousness force
mind is an experiencing station of the
great cosmic play
we are a receiving station for universal
music
[Music]
consciousness is a force
force is a self-expression of existence
all phenomenal existence resolves itself
into force
india always connected consciousness
to agni tapas heat
flame energy [ __ ] agni
there is one evolutionary force going
through
all things consciousness force
nature throws off her mask and reveals
herself as
the luminous consciousness force
carrying in her
the eternal existence and its universal
delight
of being all
existence is one being whose essential
nature is one
consciousness force of delight
the warmth of consciousness and
evolutionary force
materialism cannot maintain its validity
if there is a secret consciousness
in or behind the apparently unconscious
energy in matter e equals m c
squared there cannot be
two things consciousness and not
consciousness
one consciousness substance force
being in the world there is only one
body
the body is everywhere
it is all the same being
nine supermind
truth is the foundation of real
spirituality
courage is its soul
the truth all liberated people discover
thou art that i
and my father are one
[Music]
the truth is the kingdom of god within
the most natural thing in the world
as we awaken we feel the pressure of
eternity
and infinity you begin to feel
others as part of yourself
the world becomes our own being
reality is one experience
infinite consciousness looking at itself
from countless points of view
perception is no longer point by point
but
calm and in great masses
one does not know unless one knows with
the body don't confuse unity with
uniformity
when you gain your little drop of truth
knowledge of the whole is necessary for
right knowledge of the part
ape mind imagining mind equals
mind imagining supermind
mind begins to open to the truth that
there is something beyond itself
his evolution however obscure and slow
towards supermanhood is inevitably
predetermined
when consciousness meets the supreme
reality
in a contextual union a blaze of
intimate truth perception is lit
illuminated perception is more
comprehensive
global sympathetic all understanding
all embracing cosmic and infinite
the highest consciousness integralizes
unifies and harmonizes the many-sided
truth
supermind is individual cosmic and
transcendent
simultaneity is the key to real life
is truth consciousness wisdom love
thinking spherically integrally a
complete
embrace of all three tenses
nothing to the supermind is finite
no walls of limitation it is oceanic
ethereal supermind
power is attained only when one is
completely poised
on the eternal foundation outside time
outside space supermind
or the truth consciousness is the real
creative
agency of the universal existence
truth consciousness sees the universe
and its contents
as itself in a single indivisible
act of knowledge
unity consciousness completes truth by
broadening man's perspective
to the one truth of which all are the
aspects
unity consciousness is also light time
and distance are reduced
to nothing they have been conquered
supermind in matter pushes to evolve
from within
via spiritual yearnings aspirations to
immortality
truth beauty and is pressed from above
like the sun breaking the skin of a seed
from its own eternal plane via
intuitions
revelations and illuminations
the spiritual perfection of the being a
divinization of the mind the heart
and the very body a fulfillment
exceeding the individual transformation
a new earth and heaven a city of god
a divine descent upon earth a reign of
the spiritually
perfect the kingdom of god not only
within us
but outside in a collective human life
truth consciousness realizes itself
inevitably in time and space
the veil is thick but the light in the
hidden crypt
of the heart's innermost sanctuary is
strong
development is aided by the mind's clear
perception
and insistence on an effort to know its
nature
the super mental and spiritual being
must be created as the first unveiled
manifestation
of the truth of the self and spirit in
the material universe
supermind and superman must manifest and
take the lead of the creation
omnipresence omniscience omnipotence
of the divine being everywhere
all-knowing unlimited power
truth conscious possessed
of the seer will a perfect
and direct knowledge
we enter a vast featureless
impersonality
becoming aware of the unchanging self
the formless infinite the nameless
absolute
supermind is a state of being which
enables the absolute to flow
through you and manifest in the physical
universe it is my path
that men follow from all sides
10 the absolute one and many
truth beyond universe
sleep opens a natural window into the
absolute
absolute is both the stable and the
moving
reality is neither real nor unreal
it is a paradox a super rational
enigma the absolute
manifests itself as a being and a
becoming
the being is the fundamental reality the
becoming is a dynamic creative energy
working
out of the being becoming can only know
itself wholly
when it knows itself as being
becoming arrives at self-knowledge and
immortality when it knows the supreme
and
absolute and possesses the nature of the
infinite and eternal
know yourself as infinite in essence but
also as the infinite
self-expressed in the finite this
realization
is the culmination of the becoming the
fulfillment of the being
in its dynamic reality
[Music]
the possibility of the divines unfolding
in the individual is the secret of the
enigma
this intention of self-unfolding is the
key to the world of knowledge ignorance
man becomes the central instrument to
earth
heaven and the supreme reality
the whole play of consciousness depends
on the embodied being
religion's real business is to prepare
man's mind
life and bodily existence for the
spiritual consciousness to take it up
it has to lead him to that point where
the inner spiritual
light begins fully to emerge at that
point
religion must learn to subordinate
itself
to not insist on its outer characters
but to give
full scope to the inner spirit itself to
develop
its own truth in reality
all these variations were necessary
evolutionary
endeavor of nature has experimented on
all lines
in order to find her true way and
her whole way towards the supreme
consciousness
and the integral knowledge
this is everywhere the process of nature
and to ignore it
is to miss the intention of her works
and get lost in the maze of her
procedure
consciousness must pass beyond finite
reason
to a larger spiritual sense in touch
with the consciousness of the infinite
the individual need only to transcend
his small separate ego existence
and he can approach the absolute
the individual must arrive at divine
universality and supreme
infinity live in it possess it
to be know feel and express that
alone in all his being consciousness
energy
and delight he must arrive at a supreme
divine infinite eternal permanent
perfection to which all
tends and aspires only as the
individuals become
more and more conscious can the group
being also become more and more
conscious the great evolutionary periods
of humanity
have taken place when the individual
became active
mentally vitally or spiritually alive
whatever perfection the collective seeks
can come
only by the perfection of the
individuals who constitute it
the individual is indeed the key of the
evolutionary movement
for it is the individual who finds
himself
who becomes conscious of the reality
his own life and the world life would be
to him
like a perfect work of art the creation
of a cosmic and spontaneous
genius free and perfect self-expression
no longer seeking no longer bound to
unconscious ignorance
simply raptured in the delightful play
of existence
he individualizes the divine
transcendence
richness of diversity in the
self-expression of oneness
would be the law of the gnostic life
abandon all dharmas all standards and
rules of being in
action and take refuge in me alone
indivisible but as if divided in
beings diversity in oneness
is the law of the manifestation the
supramental unification and
integration must harmonize these
diversities
he who reconciles the one and the many
the eternal
unity and the eternal multiplicity
reunites their soul with god
and discovers the divine in the universe
a multiplicity of beings finding through
the free and luminous play of their
divine individuality
all the many fold joy of their
difference
in oneness a unifying and
harmonizing knowledge is what finds the
way
where oneness and integrality are native
the true way of individual and communal
living
the gnostic being will not accept to
live for the ego
or the state he will be aware of
something greater than these
half-truths aware of the divine reality
for that universality and transcendence
he will live the law of hunger must give
place progressively to the law of love
the law of division to the law of unity
the law of death to the law of
immortality
such is the necessity justification
culmination and self-fulfillment
of the desire that is at work in the
universe
the truly ethical being does not need a
system of rewards and punishments to
follow the path of good and shun the
path of evil
virtue to him is its own reward
sin brings with it its own punishment in
the suffering of a fall
from his own law of nature this
is the true ethical standard
in order for you to have taken up the
sophisticated human life
you must have attended the evolutionary
school of lower life forms
developing the soul's unique angle
beneath his layers
spiritual evolution is the value of the
lessons of experience
in the soul's cosmic training carry the
lens of the many
and the one the one knowing itself as
the many
and the many knowing themselves as the
one
the many ever mounting up attracted to
the one
is the eternal culmination and blissful
justification of all their play of
difference
the unity is a basis for the
manifestation
of the multiplicity and the multiplicity
is the basis for the return to oneness
oneness and multiplicity in perfect
harmony and unison
unity in all divisions and diversities
is the mathematics of the infinite
the rule of conscious unity in
differentiation
the joy of the differentiation is
necessary to the fullness of the joy of
the unity
carries all divergences in itself as its
own opulence
a multiplicity of views bringing out the
unity of the thing
seen a diverse presentation of
concomitant
aspects of the one reality
establish the delight of separation in
the midst
of an eternal unity and intermissions
use individualization of body
as the joy of the infinite in the finite
an individual dealing with other
individuals but
always in unity this is what the world
really is
the fundamental error of mind is
conceiving its individuality as a
separate fact instead of as a form of
oneness
divinely perceive individuality
each with the one and supreme dwelling
in them
the self inhabiting all is the basis of
our individuality in the universal
the one that inhabits all
the one manifests infinitely in endless
diversity
a great diversity in liberty of
self-expression
based on an underlying unity harmony and
truth of order
the delight of the spirit is ever new
the forms of beauty it takes
innumerable it's godhead ever young
in the taste of delight of the infinite
eternal and
inexhaustible absolute omnipotence
working through labor struggle
difficulty
to achieve its secret intention is a
sign
proof reality that the greatest is
possible
unflinching drive towards enlightened
civilization
imaginations that persist in the human
mind
like the idea of travel in the air and
often by
self-fulfillment individual thought
formations
can actualize themselves if there is
sufficient strength in the formation
or in the mind that forms it especially
if they are supported in the collective
mind
creative self-knowledge and all
knowledge
as in science so in metaphysical thought
the ultimate solution integralizes all
knowledge
into an all-reconciling oneness
beyond the duality and the non-duality
there is
that in which both are held together and
find their truth in a truth which is
beyond them
what our mind sees as contraries are
complementaries to infinity
infinite is capable of a manifold action
of consciousness between polarities of
ignorance and knowledge
knowledge signifies a consciousness of
the truth
ignorance is unconsciousness of the
truth
man's highest knowledge is when the veil
is broken
and he can see entering into the light
in which there
is no ignorance ignorance is the absence
of the divine
eye of perception the supreme
experience integralizes all knowledge
and experience the ultimate
consciousness sees reality as a whole
indivisible whole vision
in unveiled perception the individual
perceives its true self to be one
in being with the transcendence seated
and dwelling within it the universe is a
manifestation
of an infinite and eternal all-existence
the divine being dwells in all that is
the deeper eternal self throws out a
surface being
as the adventurer in time speculator of
infinite possibilities
lost in the labyrinth of its own
creation we reconquer
ourselves through checkered joy and pain
in an
aonic passion and seeking endeavor
the evolutionary character of the
integral becoming
becoming is the only being
all things are self-deployings of the
divine knowledge
all things are variable self-expression
of
one invariable and all-embracing delight
of self-existence
to dwell in our true being is liberation
to be fully is to be universally
transcendentally a timeless eternal
being widen yourself
indefinitely into the cosmic existence
around you
feel yourself universal one with all
existence
integral oneness is the truth of
existence
self-conscious infinity
falsehood draws its being from the truth
[Music]
[Music]
you